Today's lecture basically is titled a Union without power.
Um,
in past years I've titled it powers of powers,
problems of the confederation,
and you'll see why by the end of the lecture.
Um,
on Tuesday,
I started to talk about the larger question of the legacy of the revolution in
the process of governance and I started us off by talking about the drafting of
state constitutions and the drafting of the articles of confederation and in a
sense,
one uniting theme that ran through both parts of that lecture was the ways in
which the states and their rights and their sovereignty.
We're really at the center of things.
I mean,
in a way you could say that that entire lecture was about the states,
even though it was about really talking about a way to unify them.
Certainly you can see that in the content of the articles themselves and the
ways in which they were largely centered on defining and limiting the amount of
power that was given to the Confederation Congress.
Well,
today what we're going to look at is the impact of that.
We're going to basically be looking at how the articles played out in the
seventies and eighties given the amount of power that they had or the amount of
power that they didn't have,
but one way or another we're going to see what happened in the 1780s and as an
introduction to that.
I want to talk for just a few minutes about some of the actual debates in
Congress about the articles themselves,
some of the things that gave people in Congress pause when the articles were
being written because as you'll see,
this reveals a lot about the mindset of the time regarding centralized power and
state power and understanding that mindset is going to explain some of what
we're going to see in the bulk of today's lecture,
which is really going to be looking at events that took place in the 70s and
eighties I'm also going to mention these things right now that I'm going to talk
about briefly because in a couple of lectures from now when we begin talking
about the constitution,
you're going to see them basically all crop up again.
So just a few minutes about the debate over the articles.
Now,
one thing worth noting is that even as Congress was trying to figure out some
form of union,
even the people on the committee appointed to draft the articles of
confederation were not entirely at ease with the idea of centralizing power in
that way.
So this is just a random comment,
but it's from Edward Rutledge of South Carolina and it's a private letter that
he wrote to a friend and he was actually on the congressional committee that was
given the task of writing,
coming up with something that would be ultimately the articles of confederation.
So this is what Rutledge says to his friend.
If the plan now proposed should be adopted,
nothing less than ruin to some colonies will be the consequence.
The idea of destroying all provincial distinctions and making everything of the
most minute kind bend to what they call the good of the whole is in other terms
to say that these colonies must be subject to the government of the eastern
provinces,
the force of their arms,
I hold exceeding cheap,
but I dread their overruling influence in council.
I dread their low cunning and those leveling principles,
which men without character and without fortune in general possess,
which are so captivating to the lower classes of mankind and which will occasion
such a fluctuation of property as to introduce the greatest disorder.
I am resolved to vest the congress with no more power than what is absolutely
necessary for.
I am confident if surrendered into the hands of others.
A most pernicious use will be made of it.
Okay,
so listen to some of what relish just said there.
Okay.
He's afraid that making everything Ben to the good of the whole is basically
saying the same thing as subjecting all of the colonies to the eastern provinces
and by eastern provinces.
He means New England.
He says,
well as soon as we do sort of bend the,
my newest thing to the good of the whole New England is just going to take over.
That's basically what he is saying in that letter.
I don't want to be ruled by New England and then right after that he says the
force of their arms,
I hold exceeding cheap.
Okay.
I'm not scared of them militarily.
Like we could beat them in a fight.
However,
that low Cunnington those kinds of people have,
they will take over in councils,
right?
They'll control congress.
I don't like the whole idea of being governed by New England and because of
that,
I'm not entirely sure about this whole articles of confederation idea.
So it how's that for spirit of League of friendship that guys on the committee,
this actually drafting the document and he's that suspicious about regional
prejudices about New England trying to take over.
So that just gives you a little bit of a sense of how uneasy people were with
centralizing power in any way on this sort of national [inaudible] kind of
level,
particularly given their fears about giving up some of the power and sovereignty
that was held by their own independent states.
Now,
once congress actually began debating the articles,
there were actually three main controversies I'm going to bring up now and for
obvious reasons as I mentioned them because you'll,
you'll see why they all come up again.
As soon as we begin talking about the constitution.
These three things all helped to slow down and complicate debate over the
articles so that even though they start talking about the articles in 1776
there's a reason why it takes all the way until November of 1777 for Congress to
decide that they're done with them.
Okay,
so the first of these three controversy's,
not surprisingly I,
but I can even ask you to guess them.
You probably would guess them,
but the first one is representation.
Surprise,
not a surprise at all.
The idea of representation caused an extended over whether voting in Congress.
Once again,
it should be based on population,
which is what the larger states want or one vote,
one state,
which is obviously what the smaller states want.
As James Wilson of Pennsylvania put it,
it is strange that annex in the name of state to 10,000 men should give them an
equal right with 40,000 this must be the effect of magic,
not a reason.
Okay.
That argument appears almost verbatim,
but certainly that argument appears again once,
once again,
we're talking about representation,
centralized power,
the constitution,
not surprisingly related to representation.
The second controversial topic I'm going to raise here is taxation.
There was an extended debate over whether the common expenses of the war should
be divided up among the states on the basis of total population,
including slaves or on the basis of the free population only.
So here we have taxation,
representation and slavery all bound together happily in one issue that
obviously is going to be controversial and obviously is not going to go away.
And he's going to come back to the very next occasion when they're talking about
representation,
centralized power,
so representation,
taxation.
And the third main controversy that slowed down the passage of the articles was
the question of the West Western territories.
Not surprisingly,
there was a big division between large landed states with extensive western land
claims.
States like Massachusetts,
Connecticut,
New York,
Virginia,
North Carolina,
and small landless states like Maryland,
Delaware,
New Jersey,
New Hampshire.
Landless States saw the Confederation Congress as a sort of successor to the
crowns,
property rights in the West.
So,
in other words,
smaller states,
landless states wanted Congress to take over vast western territorial claims and
then convert them into some kind of a common stock of land who sale could help
discharge some of the national war debt.
So that's what the,
the smaller states or the landless states want.
And the idea behind that,
the logic behind that was that what was gained at common expense,
independence and control of those western lands should be used for common
benefit.
Now obviously the states that owned western lands are going to feel really
differently about that whole issue,
but it's not surprising that that would be a point of controversy.
Okay.
So those are three central concerns over the articles,
representation,
taxation,
and the western lands thanks to issues like those.
The articles were debated from mid 1776 through November of 1777 when they
finally were completed and then submitted to the states for ratification.
The main reason why debate stopped at that point in 1777 is not because everyone
decided those questions had been settled,
but because of the American victory at Saratoga.
So basically people realized if the states weren't United into one joint
political entity at that point it would be almost impossible for them to get
foreign aid.
They had to at least prove that they could unite somehow if they were going to
convince foreign countries that it was worthwhile investing in whatever was
happening in America.
So signing the articles of confederation and sending them off for ratification
was a way of giving,
added credence to the American cause in the eyes of the world at a very
strategic moment as Samuel Chase of Maryland road,
right in the midst of the debate over the articles,
what contract will a foreign state make with us when we cannot agree among
ourselves is a pretty good point.
This basic reality led Congress to complete the article,
send it to the states,
the states,
ultimately they discuss them.
Some came to a conclusion quicker than others and it was not until 1781 that the
articles formally were put into effect.
Now I want to turn to what happened once the article is actually went into
effect.
And as we set out into this discussion,
I want to take just a moment here to defend the articles just a little bit.
And I did this a little bit in,
in Tuesday's lecture too because as you'll see,
it'll be very clear by the end of this lecture why I'm doing this.
Um,
it's very easy to listen to what happened in the seventies and eighties and
conclude this is the most inadequate,
goofy form of government I can possibly imagine,
right?
Cause all we're going to see in this lecture is one after another after another
instance of this government not working so well.
Um,
and it doesn't help that you have all of these really strident nationalist in
this time period.
We're going to hear from a couple of them too,
who threw out the 1780s is for some of them,
even in part of the 1770s felt really strongly that there needed to be a
stronger centralized government and were really vocal in expressing their doubts
and expressing what they thought really needed to happen.
So Hamilton,
Alexander Hamilton's always griping about the weak government.
George Washington always griping about the weak government added to the sort of
bad PR for the articles of confederation are the federalist essays,
and I'll talk about them in a couple of lectures too,
but as we'll see when we look at them,
the federalist essays are not objective.
They're written with an agenda.
I'll go more into this in more detail later,
but they are aimed at proving that the proposed constitution is absolutely
necessary and one of the ways in which they did that was to just rip the
articles of confederation to shreds,
right?
To prove that the constitution was really necessary.
One of the things the federalist essays really try to accomplish is proving how
horrible and incompetent and in an inadequate the articles of confederation are.
And if you believe that,
then you're going to be even more likely to think,
oh wow,
they're so bad.
Maybe this constitution actually really is.
We absolutely have to go for it.
So it was part of their sort of rhetorical strategy and the federalist essays to
make the articles look really bad.
Not that they need a lot of help necessarily,
but they were really emphasizing that in the federalist essays.
So for a moment,
all I'm trying to say with this is just consider that there are all of these
reasons why for natural reasons,
for bad PR reasons,
um,
it's natural for us to look at the articles and think of them as just a big
mistake.
But of course the problem with that kind of reasoning is presentism,
right?
It's judging the articles based on what we know comes next.
So we know like write down the pike,
there's a constitution just waiting to happen.
So we know there's a stronger government coming.
We know that it works because it's still working.
So we know in a sense the end of this particular story and knowing that it's
very hard for us to look at the articles and give them,
they don't get much respect to keep very much respect to the articles of
confederation.
But that's not quite fair to judge those historical actors in that moment,
in that way.
Because of course they don't know what's coming next.
They're acting in the moment.
They're acting based on lessons they've just learned with the knowledge of the
moment.
So I think rather even after everything I say in today's lecture,
rather than condemning the articles as a kind of broken or faulty or sad system
of government,
we should instead really understand them in the context of the time and really
understand the ways in which they represent precisely what should have been the
first attempt at a national government based on the fears and assumptions that
prevailed in the United States at that time.
As I talked about on Tuesday,
there were natural fears about a strong centralized national government and of
course there were given the revolution has just happened and given that people
could look back on the revolution and say,
well,
okay,
we know that the continental congress had problems but we won.
People had some reason to assume,
well that worked basically.
So we'll kind of assume that some version of that we'll continue to work as long
as we have some kind of a sense of common purpose and there is the problem and
that is what we're going to see today.
Because the unhappy surprise of the 1780s was that once the war was over,
there was not all that much of a sense of common purpose anymore.
So as I detail all of these problems today with the articles,
try to bear in mind that yes,
they did not function as well as people maybe hoped they would,
but that rather than a stupid mistake,
they were a logical first step in a larger process of nation making.
They made sense as a first step.
Now,
even before some of the problems of the 1780s began to unfold,
there were already people who felt that the continental congress had been
frustratingly,
we heard about some of these couple of weeks back.
Um,
and not surprisingly,
people who'd been angry about the continental congress are now irritated with
the Confederation Congress too often,
or at least some of these people had experienced in one way or another firsthand
frustrations because of what they viewed as the inadequacies of these various
congresses.
So for example,
I mentioned I think actually in an earlier lecture that there were some people
at Washington's headquarters during the war who experienced firsthand how hard
it was for Congress to get them supplies and men,
partly just because congress wasn't functioning necessarily very well.
And so a lot of people that Washington's headquarters during the war ended up
being really strong.
Nationalists and Hamilton and Washington obviously are among that group,
but there's a whole string of other people as well who are all writing letters
to each other throughout the 1780 sing,
ah,
we're dying.
It's all going down to,
oh well you fought the war.
We won.
Now what's happening?
We'll hear a Washington letter along these lines and just a couple of minutes.
Other people who are unhappy with the Confederation Congress,
where people who had attempted to deal with foreign affairs during the
revolution and again on that front had seen how congress had dilly dallied.
It had failed to give effective,
efficient concrete instructions.
And John Jay was one of those people who distrusted what was I ever was going to
happen with the articles because he'd seen what happened with a similar congress
during the revolution.
Some other people had been actual members of the continental congress and found
themselves frustrated at some point about getting things implemented.
And James Madison falls into that category.
And obviously I'm just naming a few random instances here.
There are many other people who felt this way.
These men perceive what seemed to them like a supreme irony.
It would be the ideals and principles of the revolution that would tear apart
the new nation that the revolution had created.
So in their mind,
all of these fears about state sovereignty,
about concerns,
about centralized power,
about tyranny,
about protecting property,
about protecting liberties,
all of those things might actually lead people to be so distrustful of a
government that maybe it would bring the entire experiment in government
crashing down almost before it had had a chance to begin.
Now,
what was it that so upset these men about the 1780?
So let's turn to some of the events of the 1780s and see now for one thing right
off the cuff,
the state of foreign relations in the 1780s seemed alarming to them,
particularly regarding Great Britain.
Despite the fact that Americans had won the war,
that they had to go shake it.
A treaty with Britain that had cleared terms in it,
Britain was still putting up barriers and hurdles and basically not being very
cooperative.
So throughout the 1780s,
they largely refuse to cooperate with aspects of the Treaty of Paris.
So for example,
although they had agreed to abandon their posts in the western territories,
they just didn't,
sorry,
we're still here.
Um,
they also have implemented a number of different trade restrictions.
Some of them were implemented not just towards the United States,
but America for example,
found itself suddenly unable to import,
um,
like machine tools to build manufacturing,
institutions to build factories in America.
Suddenly America found itself unable to import these things.
There are other places who also were not being able to take these things from
Britain,
but now that suddenly Americans out of the British imperial system,
they don't have access to things that they once had access to before in Britain
is certainly not being cooperative on that front.
Along similar lines,
the French and the Spanish were also proving difficult,
doing things like attempting to exercise control over the Mississippi,
uh,
to control shipping,
holding back attempts by Americans to expand throughout the area.
So just on the foreign affairs front alone,
things don't look really thrilling and it's not at all clear what this congress
is going to be able to do about it.
And you can hear the impact of these kinds of developments in a letter that
Washington wrote to a friend,
and this is as early as 1784,
the disinclination of the individual states to yield competent powers to
Congress for the federal government.
They're unreasonable jealousy of that body and of one another.
And the disposition which seems to pervade each of being all wise and all
powerful within itself will if there is not a change in the system,
be our downfall as a nation.
This is as clear to me as the ABC.
This is clear as the alphabet,
but that's a weird Washingtonian version of it.
This is clear to me as the ABC and I think we have opposed Great Britain and
have arrived at the present state of peace and independency to very little
purpose.
If we cannot conquer our own prejudices,
the powers of Europe began to see this and our newly acquired friends,
the British are already acting upon this ground and wisely to,
if we are determined to persevere in our folly,
they know that individual opposition to their measures is futile and boast that
we are not sufficiently United as a nation.
To give a general one is not the indignity alone of this declaration sufficient
to stimulate us to vest more extensive and adequate powers in the sovereign of
these United States.
Okay.
That's one passage of a stream of letters of this sort that are being sent back
and forth throughout the 1780 so of course they're being sent from one
nationalist guy to another nationalist guy.
So they're,
they're sort of preaching to the choir,
right?
This is our whole,
yes,
it's horrible.
It's really horrible.
Yes,
it's really horrible things.
They all agree with each other,
but they all strike that kind of a tone.
So that's just in the world of foreign affairs domestically,
things seemed equally alarming.
The Confederation Congress could not even manage to consistently summon a quorum
of states so that they could conduct business.
Typical of many complaining letters of the period is one by Rufus king of New
York in 1785 and he wrote to a friend,
we have only five states represented.
Pennsylvania and Connecticut are expected.
And when they are here,
we can form a house.
Oh boy,
we're going to be almost able to actually do something as soon as Pennsylvania
and Connecticut get here.
Thank you very much.
Again.
Not a lot of excitement and power and energy being vested in this congress.
Why were there so few delegates even bothering to attend Congress?
Well,
for one thing,
as I sort of hinted in the last lecture,
people were much more interested in what was going on in their own states.
So a lot of people just remained at home centralized issues that affected other
states very often seem to people to be of secondary importance to concerns in
their own state.
And an extreme example of what I'm talking about here,
a sort of good example of people being more concerned with their own state.
Then with anything national in scope took place in Vermont beginning in 1777 and
continuing through the seventies and eighties now basically for a long period of
time,
New York and New Hampshire both claimed possession of the territory that
eventually would become the state of Vermont.
Well,
in 1777 residents of that territory led by Ethan Allen declared their
independence from New York and New Hampshire.
So the revolution is inspiring in many ways and here you can see the power of
the revolution.
We're declaring our independence,
so they declare themselves quote to the Independent Republic of Vermont.
We are now of the independent republic of Vermont.
So there and they actually begin to write up their own constitution and you,
you can really see the influence of revolutionary events.
Naturally enough,
the governor of New York became concerned about this because to him,
part of his State was trying to succeed and this was not a good thing.
So he pleaded with New York's congressional delegates to please do something
like maybe declare that that territory belongs to New York and get the other
states to agree with this.
So this problem will go away.
New York's governor,
as well as a number of other people became more concerned when they heard that
Ethan Allen was supposedly negotiating in one way or another with the British to
abandon Vermont's claims to independence if the British would recognize their
separate status,
supposedly.
So,
okay.
Supposedly we have a territory declaring itself an independent republic and then
negotiating with the British in the middle of the war.
Right.
Except this is a republic and we won't fight for independence.
It's a little alarming.
So among all of the reasons why that's unacceptable and alarming.
One major reason is it obviously represents the dismemberment of potentially two
states,
right?
In New York and New Hampshire.
So what does the Congress do?
Nothing as a delegate from Maryland road home to his state governor.
He had been called back to Congress because of the supposed crisis of Vermont.
But quote,
we have business enough on our hands without carving out more at this time.
So this guy is basically saying,
you know,
please,
we have enough to do,
I don't care about this whole thing is Vermont thing.
What a pain.
Like why don't they just sort of deal with it up there wherever it's happening.
Vermont seeing something of a lack of action on the national front became a
little more aggressive,
began to annex to their republic's.
Some towns in New Hampshire,
there were a little few little skirmishes with New York in 1781 on the border
and then ominously everything got very quiet on the border between Vermont and
Canada.
Right?
So people get in their thinking if these guys let somehow negotiating with the
British is there's some weird thing happening between these guys and the British
and now people are sort of skirmishing about borders in New York.
What congress kind of panicked at this point because all of this up and it seems
scary,
strange and potentially threatening.
So they made some sort of a vague counter deal with Vermont that's like,
okay,
you okay?
Okay.
Like we'll,
we'll,
we'll sort of think about this whole statehood thing.
Vermont certainly held back from talking with the British and then Congress
failed to follow through at all.
So nothing happened.
Yorktown and the seeming end of the war came 1781 the British lost interest in
Vermont.
Congress lost interest in Vermont and Vermont remained in this kind of limbo,
unknowing what it was.
Is it an independent republic?
Is it part of New York?
Is it part of New Hampshire?
Is it a state?
Is it not a state?
And this persisted throughout the entire 1780s this weird limbo for the people
of Vermont.
Nobody really quite deciding what was going on.
A similar problem took place when part of North Carolina attempted to secede
from the state of North Carolina and declared itself the state of Franklin.
We are now the state of Franklin.
I just love the fact that the revolutions inspiring all these people to declare
themselves independent states.
So in 1784 basically the way that this works is you have people living on the
western territories,
the western edge of,
of lands that belonged to North Carolina,
and they hear that North Carolina Ted contribute to the paying back of war debts
is going to give up these western lands to the congress.
Right?
I've already talked about that being discussed.
So these people in this Western territories say,
oh great,
well if the lands are being given up to Congress,
then we're kind of independent.
So they petitioned congress and say,
fine.
Then we are now the independent state of Franklin recognize us as a new state
and they began drafting their own constitution I think in 1785,
like learn independent state and now we're going to have a new republican
constitution,
um,
some Western territories of Virginia disgust joining the state of Franklin.
There was some discussion of the Cherokee being accepted into the state of
Franklin.
Okay.
So we have a little brewing new state happening here near North Carolina.
The problem is North Carolina took back their session of Western lens that there
was a whole flurry of controversy about this issue and were other states giving
up their land?
Yes.
No,
we don't know.
So North Carolina said,
well forget it.
Whatever.
We're not,
you're not getting the land.
This now left the people of the state of Franklin in a state of limbo and they
petitioned to Congress and asked,
well,
please like give us statehood.
We don't know what's happening with all this land stuff,
but hey,
we're here drafting a constitution,
give a statehood.
And ultimately Congress didn't really act concerning the state of Franklin and
it's North Carolina that ultimately dealt with the question and suppressed the
problem.
There's a there when I was poking around,
um,
researching this this morning I found some book,
I think it's called something like the last state of Franklin.
It's like the lost city of Atlantis,
the law state to Franklin at this little tiny moment of almost existing and then
poof,
it was put out okay.
So faced by the seeming dismemberment of states based by at least discussion of
a joining the British during the war,
Congress has not,
we have not seen a lot of action here on the part of the congress.
Now in these cases,
Congress just couldn't muster the interest or the energy to act on behalf of
these individual states and other cane cases.
Congress actually did respond,
but it had no power to do anything other than observe and report and advise.
So for example,
during the early seventies and eighties there was a boundary dispute between
Pennsylvania and New York and the Congress actually appointed a committee to
investigate the issue.
And the committee actually reported a decision about where they thought the
boundaries should fall.
So there is a case in which congress acts and says,
okay,
this is where the boundary should be.
End of controversy,
you would think,
but of course,
no,
because in 1784 despite the fact that Congress had supposedly decided the issue,
Pennsylvania sent someone to New York to investigate the issue,
and this is the letter of introduction sent to introduce this Pennsylvania and
agent to New York's governor quote.
It becomes our duty to be prepared in the best manner we can for opposing
attempts that threatened the honor,
the piece and the welfare of Pennsylvania.
Okay.
Is this like a vaguely threatening letter?
So Congress has done what it thinks it's supposed to do,
but it has no power to enforce it.
It's just said,
yeah,
we think the boundaries here and Pennsylvania basically says,
we don't really care.
We're going to go to New York and fight it out with them and figure out where
the boundary is.
So here it's almost as though Congress has not acted.
Their ruling is almost irrelevant here.
So clearly we're seeing some of the problems inherent in Congress just not being
able to enforce decisions
with no central control of finance,
no effective way for Congress to overcome state rivalries,
interstate commerce,
all these things are sort of brewing up.
Logically interstate commerce between states becomes a big issue in the 1780
eighties I'm not going to go into it in great detail here,
but we will be seeing soon that ultimately it's problems of interstate trade and
complications between dozens of separate sort of system set up between different
states to trade.
That ultimately really helps lead to what becomes the constitutional convention.
Again,
things that are sort of,
you can,
you can harken right back to the revolution.
People are worried about shipping and control of shipping,
customs duties,
control of trade and makes sense that states would be feeling sensitive about
surrendering any control for those sorts of things to some kind of a centralized
power.
So again,
logically enough that's going to continue to be an issue and ultimately becomes
a big enough issue that it leads to a series of steps that gets us to the
constitutional convention.
Okay.
So we've seen so far a little cluster of different kinds of problems affiliated
with the articles of confederation.
Many of these came into play in what was essentially for many at the time at
least a low point for the Confederation Congress that took place in September of
1786 and that's Shay's rebellion.
It's a controversy that ended up being a great PR tool for extreme nationalists
who really wanted to reform the articles of confederation.
In September of 1786 farmers in Massachusets began to protest about the fact
that their property was being seized because they were unable to pay off their
debts and were unable to pay state taxes.
And at first,
many of these Massachusetts farmers protested in kind of a traditional way,
and we've seen these ways before they wrote petitions then when they didn't feel
like their petitions were being listened to,
they stage sort of ritualistic demonstrations when these didn't work,
that however the farmers began to murmur that their petitions were not being
respected by their government,
that they were being forced against their will to pay unfair taxes.
Sound familiar,
right?
These are revolution era complaints that are coming back and just happens to be
against the government of Massachusetts.
So here you see people in Massachusetts,
these farmers are making a pretty strong statement about how they think
government should work and about the importance of popular sovereignty.
So feeling that they're being repressed and disrespected their liberties under
attack their property under attack,
their political voice being ignored,
these farmers began to take more drastic action.
Now a large number of these protestors were led by a revolutionary war officer
named Daniel Shays and Daniel Shays actually was followed by roughly 1100 debt
ridden farmers chaise and his followers criticized their creditors and merchants
in general as a rising aristocracy bent on depriving them of their liberties.
They marched on the courts of Massachusetts and ultimately closed them demanding
that the state legislature respond to their demands in response to these actions
of the these,
these upset farmers closing down to the courts.
The Confederation Congress called out 800 Massachusetts militia men to suppress
the revolt.
The problem is the militia refused to act cause they sympathized with the
farmers.
Okay,
bad plan didn't work.
So now the local militia is entirely disregarding a request for national defense
from what's acting as the national government at the time.
Congress next responded by requesting roughly half a million dollars from the
states to raise a special special force of men to crush the rebellion.
And only Virginia responded little Virginia.
Okay,
we'll contribute a little bit of money.
No one else responded.
Okay.
Congress could not even raise money to suppress and internal rebellion.
So New England is moving into becoming up in arms and congress is trying twice
now to do something and can't.
In the end,
a number of the established elite in Massachusetts lawyers,
particularly merchants,
wealthy merchants,
were forced to come up with their own solution.
So many of the wealthiest merchants in Massachusetts and some of these lawyers
raise their own money and created their own private army to suppress the
rebellion of several thousand men.
So they funded their own army to suppress the rebellion.
Now with the history of the revolution as hindsight,
what do you think would happen when these rebellious farmers feel that a hostile
armies descending on them to steal their liberties and crush?
Right?
You're already laughing.
It's like,
yeah,
they're going to just fold and go home.
No,
they became more rebellious right now they're like staging gorilla raids against
prominent merchants and office holders trying to overthrow what they saw as the
oppressive government of the state and ultimately there were several battles
between the private army and the Massachusetts farmers.
About 50 of the farmers were wounded or killed a few dozen of the private armed
force men were wounded or killed as well,
and all of this trouble ended in roughly 1787 when an economic upturn made some
of the farmers tents easier to pay,
and many of the farmers began to see that surrounding states were not
particularly thrilled with the idea of Massachusetts going up in arms.
So some of these farmers fled rather than face whatever they fear the
consequences might be.
They went some of them to the north,
some of them to the west.
This is my favorite random factoid about Shay's rebellion guests were Daniel
Shays.
When he fled Massachusetts,
he went to the independent republic of Vermont.
It's like if I were writing the story,
I would have made him go to the independent republic of Vermont.
Okay.
So Shay's rebellion shook a lot of people,
but it was really upsetting to people who had doubts about the powers of the
confederation government because it seemed to throw a really harsh light on the
congress and how defenseless it was to maintain order.
And this was not the only uprising or the only potential uprising even in this
period that that particularly these nationalist found so upsetting,
upsetting.
I'm going to mention only two here that potential military uprisings.
And in this case,
both of these took place as the continental army was beginning to disband.
One of them ends up becoming known as the Newburgh conspiracy because it takes
place in Newburgh,
New York.
And the Newburgh conspiracy consisted of a group of disgruntled army officers
who got tired of waiting for Congress to grant them their pensions because of
course,
Congress has no way to grab them,
their pensions.
So in 1783 they formed a plan that they would refuse to disband as an army
unless they were granted their pensions.
So there's the vague threat of a COO basically from this group of officers in
Newburgh.
Like,
we're,
we're going to stay here and we're going to remain a little army unless you give
us our pensions.
And if you don't,
then we'll see what happens.
Okay?
What ultimately stopped this?
Again,
not the congress.
George Washington,
a little George Washington moment.
George Washington personally stopped the Newburgh conspiracy,
and this shows you the real power of George Washington.
He goes to Newburgh.
It's like,
oh boy,
I got to go deal with the officers at Newburg.
This is looking ugly.
He goes in person and he stands up to address the assembled officers who are
getting ready to potentially stage a coup and he's trying to plead with them,
please,
you know,
don't do this.
This is not in this for the good of the country.
But before he even really has a chance to argue anything,
he reaches in his pocket to get out his glasses so that he can read something
that he's written and he says as as he is great.
The another example of great sort of theater on the part of George Washington.
He takes the glasses out and as he puts them on,
he says,
excuse me gentlemen,
but I've grown not only gray but blind in the service of my country.
And the officers start to cry.
Oh,
we're sorry.
And of Newburgh conspiracy.
It's just the magic of George Washington's glasses.
That was it,
man knew how to like stage a moment.
Okay?
So that does actually full the Newburgh conspiracy.
There's another sort of mini semi revolt that takes place in 1783 involving
Pennsylvania soldiers,
Congress disbands,
this particular group of Pennsylvania soldiers in 1783 and sends them home with
no payment of any kind.
You know,
sorry,
we can't pay you right now.
We'll get back to you.
Okay.
This does not thrill these particular soldiers.
They hear that they've been dismissed from the army.
They hear that nothing's gonna get done about their pay.
A few hundred of them marched to Philadelphia and barricaded members of the
Confederation Congress in the State House,
sticking their band nets through the windows and making threatening gestures
like pay us now.
Okay,
so this was not thrilling to the Confederation Congress.
That was kind of a standoff where there's armed guys with bayonets surrounding
the State House and Confederation Congressman in the State House not knowing
what to do.
This sort of sputters to a close.
When several congressmen walked outside and just left and no one did anything to
them,
they were just like,
bye and I wouldn't realize,
okay,
these guys actually really don't want to hurt us.
They're just making a point and of semi Ku slash rebellion in Pennsylvania.
However,
Congress was so thrown by this that they decided Princeton might be a better
place to meet from then on,
and so they temporarily moved to Princeton,
New Jersey rather than stay in Philadelphia because Philadelphia had just become
scary.
It's worth mentioning,
I should actually mentioned that both of these events really strongly reinforced
the prevailing wig distressed of standing armies,
right?
Look at what happens when you have a standing army sitting around.
They can't help themselves.
They're always threatening to overturn the government.
So this reinforces fears of standing armies for certain,
for a while to come.
But certainly all of these incidents are really fueling the fears and the
anxieties and the concerns of these extreme nationalists who already are feeling
that this articles of confederation or not strong enough,
and now look what's happening as the 1780s are unfolding as housing or Hamilton
would write in the federalist number 21 and again,
he's writing in the federalist,
which means he really wants to make a point.
He wrote who can determine what might've been the issue of Massachusetts
convulsions if the malcontents had been headed by a Caesar or chrom?
Well,
who can predict what effect a despotism established in Massachusetts would have
upon the liberties of New Hampshire or Rhode Island of Connecticut or in New
York?
The problem demand like Hamilton and other really strong nationalists was that
Americans seem to be so focused on their individual interests,
on their states,
on their homes,
that they had seemingly forgotten how to think about themselves as Americans,
as a United people.
This concept would be at the core of the debate over the constitution,
what it be possible.
If somehow the states could agree that it was necessary to strengthen their
central government to devise some kind of government that would actually be
acceptable to all 13 states.
Were there enough common bonds?
Could Americans only be defined when pitted against enemies?
Was there no American identity in and of itself and wasn't enough to really hold
people together in some kind of unified government and during the battle to
ratify the constitution?
In 1788 Hamilton stated just that very fact.
He said the real question was about who and what.
We're Americans speaking to the New York ratifying convention.
He said it has been asserted that the interests,
habits and manners of the 13 states are different and hence it is too.
It is inferred that no general free government can suit them.
This diversity of habits has been a favorite theme with those who are disposed
for a division of our empire and like many other popular objections seems to be
founded on fallacy.
I acknowledged that the local interest of this Tate's are in some degree,
various.
Yeah,
thanks.
I guess so.
And that there is some difference in the manners and habits,
but this,
I will presume to affirm that from New Hampshire to Georgia,
the people of America are as uniform in their interest in manners as those of
any country established in Europe.
So basically Hamilton's arguing we are a common people.
When you compare us with Europe,
look at all of the similarities between us and we need a common government to
join us and American government.
This is really the theme of the nationalists who took the lead in moving the
nation towards the constitutional convention.
Now,
before I conclude this lecture,
I do want to mention one thing.
Um,
I was going to mention it a little earlier when I was talking about Shay's
rebellion,
um,
and forgot,
but I can't resist adding it in only because it's another little Yale moment and
I'm always looking for Yale moments in the revolution.
And this is another one.
It's just a random little thing that I found,
but I thought it was interesting.
Um,
it makes me realize that to be the president of Yale during the revolution was
no fun.
Right?
I think as her,
like this is just couldn't have been fun for Ezra styles.
Um,
this is actually from 17 early in 1787 and what it,
what I found was a letter from styles to George Washington and what the letter
says is one of my,
actually two of my students are one of my students,
two of my students.
Okay.
Two of my students just arrived here from Massachusetts and they were caught by
Shays rebels who kept them there for a while.
But the students spied and they like saw how many men they were basically these
two Yale students are on their way from Massachusetts here and they get caught
by Shays rebels.
And while they're there they try and like scope things out and then they come
back and they report to styles.
Like okay,
there's roughly 2,500 men.
Like they become like little war strategists and styles rights to George
Washington and says,
okay,
let me give you the update on the Shays rebels.
And he has this whole letter with like numbers and like he draws a little map,
you know,
here's where I think they are.
You know,
all from these Yale students who got captured by Shays rebels.
I love that letter because I mean,
Shay's rebellion is not something that everyone knows about Shay's rebellion,
but the Yale connection with Shay's rebellion like that,
that was news to me.
Um,
and the fact that this,
this particular one guy who student who estimates how many troops were there,
um,
styles calls him a young gentleman of solidity and good information.
He's the guy who I guess did counting and estimating.
Um,
so there are Yale students informing George Washington about the nature of
Shay's rebellion and how many men were involved.
Um,
the last thing that I'll mention before we run out of time here,
um,
again,
was another random document that I found,
but I thought it was interesting because I think we tend to think of the shays
rebels as like crazy farmers with pitchforks.
You know,
I hate taxes and the fact is,
I mean,
these actually were people with principles and ideas.
They happen to be protesting,
but they weren't crazy people with pitchforks.
And what I found was one of the generals,
you know,
one of the people sort of leading the rebels,
um,
wrote a statement to Massachusetts,
basically asking them to eliminate the private army.
But I wanted to read it to you because it gives you a sense of some of the
rationale and the feelings behind some of these Shays rebels and stated January
25th,
17,
87,
headquarters west Springfield,
again,
really gives you a sense of how the rebels envisioned themselves,
the body of the people assembled in arms,
which is they themselves adhering to the first principles of natural self
preservation do in the most peremptory mannered demand that the troops in
Springfield lay down their arms,
that their arms be deposited in the public stores under the care of the proper
officers to be returned to the owners at the termination of the present contests
that the troops returned to their homes upon parole.
Signed Luke Day,
captain,
come in,
don't have this division.
Okay,
that's by one of the rebel.
So I read that only because it kind of gets us past the crazy farmer guys with
pitchfork image that these were people really who had,
um,
a sense of principle.
And again,
a principal,
you can just hear in the language that I read,
they're inspired and driven by the revolution that they had just been through in
their mind.
It's all part of the same fight.
But you can hear just in that language,
if people are associating what's happening in the 1780 eighties to what happened
in the revolution,
and if the revolution is the story of government overturned,
again,
you can see why these nationalists would have been so disconcerted and so upset
by what they saw unfolding in the 1780s.
Right?
That already seen a pretty major government get overturned with this kind of
action during the revolution.
Now we've instituted this government and we see some of the same kind of
behavior happening again.
So what we're going to hear in the next couple of lectures is people discussing
what needs to happen.
Not everybody thinks that this is the sign of a horrible,
horrendous crisis.
But boy,
the people who really felt that the articles was a problematic government were
very loud,
and over time they become very United in thinking that there's a serious problem
about the center of government in the new nation.
I will stop there.
I will see you on Tuesday.
Have a good weekend.